i think first of all we um we felt from
the
from the first table read of the pilot
without having met
any of the others beforehand we all felt
kind of an instant chemistry
going way back david schwimmer is
getting nostalgic about the friends
reunion
the actor took to instagram to share
some behind-the-scenes pics from the
long-awaited reunion
look at this does courtney still have
her lines written on this you know what
the difference is
you know it's not no really i never knew
she did that and i saw it i was like
what is it she goes well don't
mind your business she said the first of
the picks shows
schwimmer on a zoom call with his
co-stars jennifer aniston
courtney cox lisa kudrow matthew perry
and matt leblanc which he notes that it
was them
planning the reunion another shot is a
selfie of schwimmer featuring
lisa and jen in the background gathered
on the reunion
set to take promo pics ahead of the
special's premiere
schwimber's post also included
throwbacks with the show's creators and
executive producers
kevin bright marta kaufman and david
crane
all of whom the actor wrote he's forever
grateful to
another photo featured the six cast
members in a huddle during the taping of
the series finale back in 2004
as well as an updated version of the
huddle pick which the group
recreated while taping the reunion
sentimentally noting the caption
thank you hbo max for bringing us back
together one thing that we did every
show that we didn't do that night before
we started
our hurdle straight down to this purple
door
we did the huddle right here yeah right
around yeah come on let's do it hold on
come on wait
you mean
prior to the special schwimmer and his
castmates matt leblanc and matthew perry
told et
how nostalgic it was being back together
it's been
very nostalgic and uh and
and really just heartwarming couple of
days uh being on the set
and seeing this seeing the old set and
uh seeing the crew and seeing the scene
seeing the the old guys and it's just
it's a very loving group but david
wasn't the only one feeling nostalgic
after the reunion
shortly after the premiere aniston also
shared some memories of her own
including a cast selfie a shot of
schwimmer with guest star justin bieber
and his wife haley
and a pic of herself with director james
burrows
captioning the post still basking in all
the love from the friends reunion
thank you each and every one of you all
i can say is that there was something
that was laid down at the very very
beginning that kind of went into our
neural pathways that we
instantly it was in our dna that we were
family we were going to take care of
each other
and if it's not obvious enough this cast
is having a ton of fun
on their social media including courtney
cox
i know earlier this week the friend star
took to instagram to share a video of
her and her pal ed
sheeran reenacting the routine from the
show
talk about iconic
[Music]